thank you Lauren whatever helps whatever
works more golden knights coverage for
you now while John langler may not be
here he's up covering the legislature he
never misses an opportunity though to
show off his hockey Pride he had a chat
with the golden Knight himself to talk a
bit about the Stanley Cup Final
who better to talk to than the man who
commands The Fortress himself the Vegas
golden knights sir how are you I'm very
well it's our Fortress remember for our
Fortress the people as well exactly we
are the people so tell me about the
Fortress how's it been during this quest
for the cup it's been electric the you
know the the fans are some of the best
in the NHL they really are and we've had
some fantastic banter with the
opposition fans uh thank goodness we got
rid of Edmonton because they were
Edmonton uh but you know Dallas were a
fun crowd and we were expecting the same
from uh from Florida and no popcorn
being thrown are you gonna make sure
you're gonna see to that right is the
golden Knight you're keeping an eye on
that kind of yeah no trash on the ice no
trash on the ice okay so as we're
getting ready for the game we thought Mr
Knight Mr G Knight we would show you
some pictures just to kind of get your
impression of things as we head into
this important final round of the series
so first your reaction to this picture
here sir oh the enemy they are mere
Pussycats aren't they let's be honest
though I mean you know that's what they
are yeah uh but then they're not an
attractive Bunch are they yeah I mean
look at this beard here what's I mean no
playoff beards are a thing but you got
to work on that yeah it's uh it's not
it's not a great looking bunch is it
let's be honest they're a bit of a rag
tag Bunch uh and then how about this oh
Chucky Chucky's going down Matthew could
chuck from the Florida Panthers Chucky's
going down can you do something about
this mouth guard he never has it in his
mouth eh it just it's a waste of time
isn't it really it really is it's a
waste of time all right let's just
change things up a little bit here ah
it's my little yellow friend
sorry golden friend he's changed his
look now he got a little he got a little
uh Little Sun he's now uh he's now gold
sparkly golden he's got his teeth still
as well look he's like there's no Gap in
the teeth and he's he's typical Vegas
and finally here Mr G Knight
oh don't don't come anywhere near me
with that the Holy Grail are you a
superstitious you want to touch it until
you win it no no I don't even want to be
close to it all right well let's get rid
of it quick we don't want to upset the
golden Knight here